we're joined on the line by Lindy Lee
Lindy currently helps to lead Asian
American political outreach for Joe
Biden was picked to be one of his DNC
delegates for the 3rd Congressional
District of Pennsylvania she's a proud
moderate conservative Democrat ran for
Congress in the previous cycle and holds
a leadership position within the DNC
she's been in the news recently because
she's been the subject of some pretty
vicious attacks by the Bernie Bros on
line Lindy thanks so much for joining
the ben shapiro show thank you so much
for having me
so Lindy why don't you explain first of
all what exactly happened here what made
you a Democrat the subject of so many
attacks by the Bernie bros and who are
they what do they do
it was unbelievable this has been going
on for months now this wasn't an
isolated incident it started in January
when somebody thanked me for supporting
a Jewish community every time there's
anti-semitic attack I would tweet about
it and condemn it and just someone
thanked me for being a Ruth and for
people who aren't familiar with that
Ruth to somebody who wasn't Jewish
herself but support of the Jewish
community and in that tweet in the same
tweet she said Sanders is a self-hating
Jew and so i retweeted that primarily
because she thanked me for sticking up
for Jews and I thought that was a
perfectly fine thing to say but that
just said the brain grows off so I was
suddenly called an anti-semite a piece
of racists and all sorts of things that
I probably shouldn't repeating on air
but it was just it was traumatic from
the out a number of AIPAC I support
AIPAC this is just it's inconceivable to
me I go to Shabbat most of my friends
are Jewish so to hear some of me that I
am a bigot was just unbelievable and and
I got a confession from one of these
memos saying that my actual crime wasn't
anti-semitism my actual crime was
political moderation and being on the
conservative side of the Democratic
Party and frankly they keep this up
there aren't gonna be many of us left
and so that happened a month ago but
just just last week I tweeted a video
that I'd actually been posted many years
ago and in that video Bernie Sanders
praises communist Russia and I tweeted
it out it was fine I mean I got the
usual you know flak from brain
supporters though but wasn't anything
intolerable was just like your brain
worms and your stupid and stuff
like that the bill kristol retweeted it
in that launched a chain reaction um
various high-profile commentators
retweeted the video at all and millions
of people ended up seeing that video is
included in 60 minutes clip and that was
the beginning of just a week of
Cheerilee just unbelievable hell they
went after my brother who's still in
college
a teenager um you know I was like
frankly afraid to show my face I stayed
in my apartment for a number of days it
was harrowing I've never seen anything
like it I just remember staring into the
darkest corium thinking like my heart is
counting how do I make it stop just
thousands of detects a Kalindi or a
pathological liar and all I didn't share
a video of things he actually said and
frankly he gave me much more credit I'm
not that technologically advanced I
don't know how to dub voices or change
videos it's what he said it was
extracted from the Roth Vermont Public
televisions right and sorry sorry for
going on and on but this whole thing was
just in such a traumatic experience well
I mean it is true in that the Bernie
bros are widely known for being some of
the worst people online as far as the
the Jewish attack it's always ironic to
me when I hear people who are very upset
at anybody who makes an oblique
reference to Bernie Sanders not being an
incredible Jew because he's very of
course proud to be a Jew when he is
hobnobbing with open anti-semites like
Linda Sarsour Ilhan Omar and Rashida to
leave and then recently came out as an
example and said that he's going to not
go to AIPAC because a pack is filled
with racists while simultaneously
embracing 8 4 & 8 to Hamas it so III
have questions for people who are deeply
concerned about chris matthews talking
about world war ii in a completely
different context and suddenly he's an
anti-semite but bernie can be as
anti-israel and hobnob with his mentee
anta any as many anti-semitism ons and
and if you point this out then this
makes you an anti-semite so how much of
this did you feel was was organized so I
remember back in 2016 I took a fairly
unpopular position I didn't vote for
either of the major candidates and I got
just waves of paper particularly from
the all right and it felt like it was
organized at a fair
we high-level that it was a specific
group of trolls and they were just going
to just hit you and hit you and hit you
and hit you how much of this do you
think is coming from an organized place
how much of you think T do you think
it's just sort of Twitter mobbing and
frankly what do you think Bern should do
about it because I'm I will admit Lindy
I'm a little bit of split mind on the
one hand I think the Bernie has an
actual obligation to tells people to
shut up on the other hand Bernie has a
lot of followers and it would be very
difficult for him to to control all of
his followers how much of this do you
think is due to Bernie and how much of
it do you think is just the radicalism
of Bernie's agenda attracts radicals I
absolutely think that the rod suck
starts at the top he had people like
Glenn Greenwald and David the guy who
you know always released his doctored
videos these people are on his staff you
know that he hired them he hired the
most vicious attackers to say that he
has no control over his supporters is
completely disingenuous and it's just
what does he what does the supporters
hope to achieve I'm not gonna suddenly
vote for him because he called me that's
that's I am so never Bernie it's I can't
even describe it and it's almost funny
how he almost makes Trump look good and
I by the way I just want to make clear
that I've never once been attacked by
bag of people not once and I've never
had kind things to save our presidential
I'm not you know I'm not never in my
life have I raised it but they never
attacked me they've never tried to make
me feel subhuman and frankly it's just I
can't believe it and people are actually
gonna remove me from the delegate ballot
I have a screen shot of Bernie
supporters plotting to take me off the
ballot to disqualify me that it is just
it just shows me who they are
so Linde looking at that sort of where
the Democratic Party is going obviously
South Carolina is widely perceived to be
sort of Joe Biden's last stand that if
Biden doesn't hold that Bernie in South
Carolina basically this race is over
Michael Bloomberg is tossing hundreds of
millions of dollars into the race but it
looks like it could be too little too
late if Bernie's already won the first
few primaries and if he's got all the
momentum then Bloomberg's stepping in
last minute is unlikely to stop the the
Bernie surge let's assume for a second
that Bernie does win the nomination how
many people do you think are like in the
Democratic Party obviously Biden has a
very solid base of support how many
people do you think are actually
never Bernie how many people do you
think are gonna stay home if Bernie is
the nominee and and how many people do
you think are just gonna swivel behind
Sanders no matter what just because they
dislike Trump that's a lot last group
that you mentioned I find that extremely
despicable I just um I don't want to
never vote for Bernie under any
circumstances and I'm a Democrat and
I've never voted for a Republican for
president but this is just too much it's
like psychic trauma and I have on by the
way the burning balloon infiltrated our
Twitter DM groups and screenshotted
private discussions so that's just a
picture of who they are and those people
in the groups that I mentioned they are
never Bernie and they're and we have
hundreds of people and we didn't start
out this way his supporters made us this
way well Linda Lee really appreciate
your time and and thanks for speaking
truth even when it's in a popular inside
your own party Linda Lee of course is
helping to lead agent American political
outreach before Joe Biden lynnie good
luck on everything and we'll keep in
touch and hopefully check back in with
you as the election moves forward thank
you so much and I'm really proud of you
for speaking your truth too
I appreciate it
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content